there are still endless gobs of
Republican elected officials who defend
Trump Marjorie Taylor Greene
you know the folks but
there are more and more Republican
elected officials who are saying this is
too much now I don't say that these
people are brave listen the guy's been
impeached twice humiliated the country
has been indicted twice is admitting to
crimes and speeches made in front of his
supporters
these aren't brave people for doing this
now but I care about the political
ramifications here is Ken buck
starting to go in the direction of this
may have been too much how would you
have done it if you were the prosecutor
then after 14 months of asking and then
of course seeing the surveillance tapes
that showed even after a subpoena
they didn't get the former president
defied a subpoena according to the
surveillance and it goes beyond that he
hid documents you know purposely putting
him in a shower purposely
um putting him on a stage so there there
clearly is an intent uh to hide there
was an incent that he knew it he talked
to his attorneys so great uh these
documents no doubt that that it was a
difficult situation it's just a
precedent from my position my my view of
searching a former president's home uh
that that is just unseemly in in this
country I don't know what the answer is
whether there were Alternatives or not
I want to ask about
the notion of the former president being
a candidate for president again as you
said he is innocent until proven guilty
that is the way the system works and
should work but given the allegations
you just discussed some of them the
specifics of the way he allegedly
mishandled classified information would
you feel comfortable with Donald Trump
as president again well I would not feel
comfortable with a convicted felon in in
the white house so what a big boy How
brave Now understand even for Ken Buck
like he's still saying a convicted felon
certainly the allegations against Trump
wouldn't influence his vote but he is at
least drawing some Line in the Sand as
pathetic and weak I mean it's it it is a
cop-out but it's also pathetic that this
is what it takes to get them to even
revise their thoughts then Mike Pompeo
went on Fox News yesterday and he also
is saying this is extraordinarily
serious so what Donald Trump is facing
and is it right to charge him
Brian good morning great to be with you
uh two things I think are both true at
this point first if the allegations are
true and there's lots of indications
that they are President Trump had
classified documents where he shouldn't
have had them and then when given the
opportunity to return them he chose not
to do that for whatever reason that's
just Brian you talked about me having
classified documents I handled thousands
and thousands of them over my time in
Congress and then as a CI director and
Secretary of State I suppose we can all
make mistakes and get them to the wrong
place but when somebody identifies that
you got to turn them in so that's just
that's inconsistent with protecting
America's soldiers Sailors Airmen and
Marines and if the allegations are true
some of these were pretty serious
important documents now the question for
Mike Pompeo even though he's being big
and tough now is you were Secretary of
State are you saying Trump never did
anything wrong until he left the Oval
Office because that's becoming
increasingly difficult to believe from
all of these folks who say listen
everything he did as president was fine
but this one thing he did since leaving
that I'm not okay with very difficult to
believe that former uh Speaker of the
House Paul Ryan was on with CBS now he
is not a trump guy we already know that
but he is also hammering Trump very hard
from another wing of Republicans that
seem to be turning on him and this one's
National Security this one's different I
used to have these same documents myself
um as Speaker of the House so I think
this goes beyond just um some petty
thing now my guess is Trump will play
this politically pretty well and make
this weaponization argument and make
this about Joe Biden's justice
department and that's going to have some
political saliency so I don't think
Marco's wrong in saying that there's
some political sting here but I can't
help but think the weight and the
baggage of all of this and this one's
National Security this one I think we
want to nominee who's not weighed down
with so much baggage in order to win
this election all right so Paul Ryan
saying Trump is not the right guy Paul
Ryan was saying that before this second
indictment anyway Fox News senior
political legal analyst Brit Hume
actually explains the entire thing here
on the second indictment this is not an
elected official but brick Hume is sort
of the epitome of just uh put your
finger to the wind and go wherever the
Republicans want you to go he's making
it clear that this could indeed be a
moment for many Republicans to back away
from Trump what are your thoughts this
morning
well I think the two things can be true
at the same time one of them being that
there is indeed a two-tier system of
justice in which people like Hillary
Clinton uh skate while Donald Trump is
indicted for wrong and no evidence of
that at this time but okay Contin please
continue we're similar similar offense
um that does not mean however that the
indictment is not valid and serious and
its details are pretty damning and I
think that some of these politicians who
are quickly standing with Trump and and
seem not to have thoroughly read or
understood the indictment they want to
may want to back away a little bit and
and and let this let the details of this
indictment sink in and when they sink in
with the public there may be a shift in
sentiment on this that is for sure that
is for sure and we are seeing that a
couple more of these CNN reporter Manu
Raju spoke to Republican Congressman
Steve Womack and Republican Congressman
Tim Burchette and some others and many
of these are already backing away
serious concerns about anybody that has
a reckless disregard for the handling of
classified documents you're a military
guy he allegedly had National Security
information very problematic because the
reason I'm not not defending it would
you be okay with that I mean convicted
felon as your nominee
and I just have to read the conviction
but no honestly on the surface I
wouldn't that doesn't look good there
you go so a number of these Republicans
now I want to be crystal clear with you
guys
I am not presenting these to you as
examples of Bravery or uh you know moral
Clarity or any of it it is simply a sign
that this may be what allows and I think
allows really is the right word allows
Insider Republican support for Trump to
publicly collapse we're going to
continue watching it what just one more
little note on this Pence now also
saying he can't defend the allegations
in the Trump indictment Pence on the New
York indictment was saying political all
this stuff
now Pence after seeing this new Federal
indictment even Pence is saying he can't
defend that so this may be a change just
imagine where we will be seven to ten
days from now